today the commission has created a
support group for Ukraine the goal of
this support group is to help and assist
Ukraine not only in financial terms but
also its technical assistance it's
important to have this support for the
reforms political and economic reforms
ukra needs to become a sustainable
independent modern country this comes on
top of the 11 billion EUR of support in
Grants and loans that I have announced
some weeks before and this also follows
the signature of the political parts of
the association agreement signature that
took place here in Brussels with prime
minister yat senuk so this shows that
the European Union stands by Ukraine We
Believe Ukraine can be an independent
stable viable Democratic prosperous
country and I want to make it clear that
European Union stands by
Ukraine